well welcome to this game playing
Bella's from Norway yo what am I going
to go for ya opening shallows week so so
maybe the reverse Grand Prix this is
what I even played normal under normal
circumstances I once in a while so not
sure this is really counting but I
didn't nobody mentioned I cannot play
the English opening so mm maybe this one
actually should but would be okay sorry
for that yeah that is a what he chose
there is one of the best lines against
them against myself to the fairly solid
way to play for whiten some playing
efore for whitis as an idea here quite
often I'm just I'm just very simply um
centralizing things and don't don't do
anything fancy here okay yeah so f4 or
not let's go fo it's a debatable
decision because I'm weakening e4 quite
a bit but I'm giving this f5 move some
yeah some sense let's say that it is
doing something actually so mm taking
only four or not is threatening to take
f6 with check I'm checking their first I
think Knight f6 I can play rook f6 okay
it really matter much um yo so maybe 94
here actually rookie one is a move that
is irritating quite a bit I take eform
he will take with the pawn and this is a
something that is not not that
comfortable should reform hmm not so bad
hmm okay Chad's a bit lame taking them
to blame this
trying for possible Bishop f3 but no it
isn't doesn't feel too great here this
position yeah so Bishop f3 yo is this
this is bad or me bad can be bad but
does it lead to much maybe this one
actually yeah maybe this one that's a
good idea i guess if okay it does not
take but now I can go to c5 maybe maybe
can I do that let take d to hear Bishop
jigs I wonder it tooks a bit wrong this
looks wrong they should Oh Bishop c5
immediately
Bishop c5 yeah why not I can do that
immediately looking at the f to pawn
rook the eight quindi aid and it's
tricky there on f2 ok you can go look at
one but that was not his intention and I
have no intermediate move but it's okay
i mean those two bishops are unprotected
I don't see a tactic Bishop F towards
miss check so yeah I think he has to do
something like that and now um probably
still Queenie seven was some other move
okay let's do that my time situation is
also important one minute down that
looks like a very relaxed move no I know
he wants to go route if rhymes I'm sorry
am that it actually has a very concrete
idea but still
should
okay I can't go Bishop f3m let's do that
I'm just taking far too long I don't
know what it is why am I taking so long
if take them yeah but I don't have to
take now that's quite important i can go
to the six for example or can I okay
let's play that five I wasn't sure that
if five is helping him
queenie queenie to might be a problem
there ok ok ok ok ok meeeee time warning
yeah I know
now I spot that I had such a nice
position now you wonder I in which
particular moment I screwed that up hmm
can just take a seven now I believe but
I didn't like the side of side of esox
happening check it's not so easy
technically not at all my king is very
very well they're only six very very
well very good only 6k stay active
fish up here or maybe no g5 g4s better
even that's even better keeping the rock
down then Bishop c5 Bishop c5 and
possibly let's do this and then rook
air-five rookie 5 that that's nice okay
didn't see that one coming
yeah I don't have any time left them
pollution is quite nice actually I'll
check nice it's okay not the check
nothing bad Jim check okay i don't think
i'm going to do accion on position
anymore I'm running those pawns gras
offered chennai cannot that sets useless
i cannot i cannot use anymore he only
has a low in bishop but i'm too slow
here right preme chest maybe check Jeff
Jeff Jeff game not to miss ought to move
sir I'll tattoo slow that I am Ted too
slow boom John that wasn't wasn't really
great I had a nice position around here
yeah that was nice so here and I went
went there
no somewhere around here I mean it
looked quite normal but I think this is
really he's just keeping things together
them white is to slidably six is a
nonsense idea I really didn't see that
'if I've was so good one problem is that
here here if I go back this this
movement with a double check that was a
really bad thing champ gee I'm just I'm
just using this pawn them check okay he
played it in a very cooperative fashion
and here I'm not even worse anymore I'm
just so active probably be five or
something is better yeah draw is
probably a fair result from from here
his g-form was a very bad idea giving me
this activity and here I'm winning so I
think I mean he should draw I guess
maybe with this yeah if I'm trying to
enter now kruky need to know I hear this
protective so it is a draw but ok I just
two moves two or three moves and I would
have won this okay well thanks for
watching